for this video this is from about a year
and a half ago this is making the rounds
again and uh
by golly I think this might be some very
influential people sharing
misinformation this is well just take a
look and remember this from about a year
and a half ago I think you'll recognize
these fellas our fellow Americans right
now the covid-19 vaccines are available
to millions of Americans soon they will
be available to everyone the science is
clear these vaccines will protect you
and those you love from this dangerous
and deadly disease they could save your
life so we urge you to get vaccinated
when it's available to you that's the
first step to ending the pandemic and
moving our country forward it's up to
you foreign
and lies the science is clear it'll
protect you and your loved ones no it
isn't none of them got in trouble for
any of that they're also social
distancing six feet apart as if they
didn't shake hands and hug each other
right before that it's all just nonsense
our world leaders and whether it's the
whether it's the world leader leader in
quotes Klaus Schwab or the former
presidents or the machine that talks in
people's ears is that about fossil fuels
or is it about
sorry I'm getting in trouble no well no
that's while they're supposedly giving
the news I'm getting in trouble what a
bizarre thing to say on the news I'm
getting in trouble shouldn't someone be
asking who who said that something to
her why is she getting in trouble but
that they lie about everything they
could have had Joe Biden up there too
remember you uh you get the vaccine you
will got not get nor transmit coven
you're okay you're not gonna you're not
gonna get coveted if you have these
vaccinations
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]